Adam is with us in Bowling Green
Kentucky hi Adam how are you hey dave
has a gallon man better than I deserve
how can I help awesome well basically I
want you to tell me if I'm crazy I'm 26
years old I do a my own business and I
want to buy a two hundred and seventy
five thousand dollar house I have walked
my way up through yourself I have down
payment I have an emergency fund I have
held off retirement and had funded that
down payment for the house that we are
actively searching for that the main
problem is my family which the the main
advice giver is first-generation rich
he's a multi-millionaire he's telling me
that I am crazy and you know no 26 year
old needs that and I don't need it and
with a lot of you know with a lot of
good lives and a lot of things that
people tell you he's right I mean I
don't need it but I'd like it and I feel
like I'm in a financial position where I
can do without putting my you know my
wife and my son in jeopardy
what's your household income well the I
loan business last year we were about a
hundred and ten this year I think we'll
be above that I made about ten thousand
dollars last plus but usually I averaged
around five grand
but now I'll hit month I'll make 10
grand and then like December I made
$21,000 and you have no debt at all of
any kind not a cent
anybody and how much is in your
emergency fund about twelve thousand
dollars how much is in your down payment
above that about fifty thousand dollars
now my plan is to go in and buy the
house at about 250 and I feel like I can
do that it's been on the market a while
and another guy and I can beat it
negotiating laws I can I can beat them
so um well when you calculate the
payment on a 15-year fixed-rate is it
going to be more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay your average take-home pay
no it's not I mean it's hey I'm
guaranteed a certain amount of money
because we got into property management
and commercial cleaning along with
construction and so I am contract to
bring in a specified amount of money
every month and that
I could pay that if construction product
I didn't do anything but that I feel
pretty safe you bet you have been
conservative financially and you're
within the dot you're within the
conservative guidelines that we teach to
buy that home okay so no you would not
qualify as crazy or out of control or
frivolous or like you need to run for
Congress because you spend so much money
or something it's none of that okay yeah
now your dad airs more over on the side
of don't borrow for anything and take a
few more years save up and pay cash for
it and live conservatively during that
time that's not a bad idea it's actually
wisdom but it's not not to the point
that so say that you're going over the
line into crazy all that's happening
here is is the house you're buying is
nicer than his that is what it is that's
exam and it's not that he's jealous
it's that emotionally he can't wrap his
head around um that anybody needs a
house like that because he just never
been there and he doesn't mean it in a
mean way he doesn't think you're really
crazy
he just emotionally can't wrap his head
around that and I've experienced that as
I started making more money and built
more wealth over the years sometimes I
look at things I'm doing today
given my current income and my current
net worth versus like how I grew up well
and the growing up Dave
you know from Antioch Tennessee would
looked at the things that Dave does now
and said well you're out of control
you're a nut
nobody runs to dot dot dot you know I
would have said I would have said stuff
like that to me and about me but the
difference is I've been here now and I
know and so and it's kind of weird
around here I mean our business we've
got five hundred team members and so I
spent twenty thousand dollars on a
stinking server and I make that decision
you know in the computer room back here
and make that decisions in about
thirteen seconds
you used to be twenty thousand dollars
would have made my emotions just go into
my throat not I had to pray about it for
seven days and walk around the building
and click my heels together and
everything else to make that decision
right
for your perspective is totally shifted
it's our here exactly and so let's give
your dad a break because he's not being
mean it's just his perspective and by
and by the way you're not gonna fix that
I know and I I don't want to put that I
don't want to lose that relationship
because I do love my and I'm just so
just don't talk about the house okay dad
I know this and I appreciate this and
you've taught me to be conservative and
that's why I'm doing well financially
because I use your principles in general
of you know being frugal and living on
less than I make and I I'm real
conservative and I'm putting this on a
15 year and I know you don't get it dad
but just pray for me and be happy for me
because I'm going to go forward with it
and and I'd love to have your blessing
but I understand where you're coming
from dad and I love you and just kind of
have that spirit about it you know
rather than you've got to somehow
convince him for this to be okay it's
probably not going to happen that you
convince him for this to be okay Ron
paranoia and you just got you just got
that going on but the good news is he's
actually on the right side of the
equation and you can still use his
advice for other things and look at it
because he does think in the round on
the right side of this this personal
finance math equation that we all work
very few people are smart as he's been
right okay we can still still give him
great honor and we can still hear from
him on other things and but just always
stop and go okay if this feels okay to
me and I don't think I'm nuts which
you're not nuts then it must be a
perspective thing right and then that
sets you free to just love him where he
is okay you got it man thank you thank
you sir good good to have you call in
and you're doing good work with that